สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะงั้นก็เรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้า
วันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 2
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนตุลาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 1 ค่ะ
เดือนตุลาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 3 เดือนอะไรคะ
เนื้ออันตุลาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
3 โมง
ครูฟ้า 28 นาทีค่ะ
กลางวันนะคะ
เป็นช่วงบ่ายๆบ่ายๆแบบนี้เนี่ยรู้สึกอะไร
คะครูฟ้า
รู้สึกว่าง่วงนอน
กูฟ้า
แล้วจะ
ง่วงนอนใช่ค่ะง่วงนอนก็ไปนอนสิคะไปที่
เตียง
เป็นเตียง
ก็ไปนอนก่อนนะคะ
ไม่ได้ค่ะไม่ได้ไม่ได้ตอนนี้ไม่ได้ค่ะครู
ฟ้าตอนนี้ครูฟ้าต้องอยู่กับครูหญิงก่อน 20
นาทีค่ะครูฟ้า
ผู้หญิง
อะไร
ง่วงนอน
ไม่เป็นไรค่ะครูฟ้าง่วงนอน
อยากจะนอนใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ค่ะ
ไม่ได้นอนแล้วมีคนมาคุยด้วยเห็นไหม
ให้อยู่กับครูหญิงไม่เป็นไรค่ะครูฟ้าถ้า
ครูฟ้าง่วงนอนวันนี้วันนี้ 20 นาทีที่ครู
ฟ้าอยู่กับครูหญิงเนี่ยครูฟ้าจะไม่ง่วง
นอนค่ะ
จริงหรอทำไม
วันนี้ครูหญิงเนี่ยมีเกมมาเล่นกับครูฟ้า
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยต้องใช้
อันนี้อะไรคะครูฟ้า
เหมือนผีเสื้อนะ
คะฉันวาดอะไรก็คือไม่โอเคนะคะ
ไม่มีความ Abstract เลยนะคะ
นี่ไง
อันนี้คือฟ้า
แล้วก็เนี่ย
ครูฟ้าทำไมต้องให้ผู้หญิงวาด
ทำไมเหมือนผีเสื้อหรอคะเขาเป็นยังไงหรอ
ผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงก็ไม่เคยเห็นสมองครูฟ้าที่อยู่
ข้างในนี้ไงผู้หญิงไม่ได้มีมีดใช่ไหมมี
มีดแล้วก็มาผ่าหัวครูฟา
ใช่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยต้องใช้สมองแล้วก็คิดเพราะ
ว่าวันนี้ครูหญิงมีเกมมาเล่นกับครูฟ้า
แต่อาจจะไม่ได้เป็นโอเคในคอมพิวเตอร์
แต่ว่าเกมวันนี้เนี่ยครูฟ้าต้องฟังที่ครู
หญิงพูดแล้วก็ต้องคิด
ทำยังไง
ถึงจะไม่ตายคล้ายๆ Survival เกมไหม
คอมพิวเตอร์เขามี Survival เกมป่ะ
คะเขาเป็นคนที่เซอร์ไวเวอร์ได้ในทุกๆที่
นะคะนักเรียน
มาดูค่ะครูฟ้า
นี่นะคะผู้ชายคนนี้เนี่ย
เขาชื่อว่าคุณจอน
J  o  s  n
คุณพ่อ
เป็นฝรั่งเหรอคะ
ฝรั่งสิคะ
ใครก็เปลี่ยนได้นะผมสีดำก็เปลี่ยนได้ก็
เป็นฝรั่งค่ะเขาชื่อว่าคุณจอน
คุณจอย
เขาลงเขาตกลงไปอยู่ในหลุมอันนี้คือหลุมนะ
คะที่ลึกมากๆเพราะตอนแรกเนี่ยคุณจอนเนี่ย
นะคะเขาก็อยู่ตรงนี้แหละ
เขาก็อยู่ข้างบนหลุมเนี่ยแหละค่ะแต่มีคน
ไม่ดี
เป็นคนไม่ดี 1 คนเนี่ยนะคะก็หลัก
จรเนี่ยก็เลยตกลงมาอยู่ในหลุม
คุณไม่ดีคนนี้เป็น
อะไรคะครูฟ้า
คุณไม่ดีหรอคะนี่เรากำลังจะหาคนไม่ดีหรือ
เปล่า
[เพลง]
เราจะต้องขึ้นสิคะครูฟ้าเราอยู่ในหลุมแบบ
นี้เราจะต้องคิดว่า
ทำยังไงเราถึงจะขึ้นไปข้างบนได้จะได้ไหม
ตายเพราะดูจากนี้ใช่ไหมคะคิดว่าไม่ค่อยมี
คนเดินมาไม่มีรถขับผ่านถ้าจรเนี่ย
ตกอยู่ในหลุมแล้วก็ตะโกนว่าช่วยด้วยช่วย
ด้วยช่วยด้วยไม่มีใครได้ยินไง
ตอนจะต้องทำยังไงที่เขาจะไม่ตายแล้วก็
ขึ้นไปบนหลุมได้แต่ครูฟ้ารู้ไหม
คนไม่ดีคนนี้เนี่ยนะคะ
มิสเตอร์
อันนี้ชื่อจอนอันนี้ชื่ออะไรดีอ่ะ
เจมส์
ดูวีดีโอใจเลยผมเป็นคนไม่ดีเหรอเอ้าก็จอด
กับเจมส์ใช่ไหมคนไทยก็มีชื่อเยอะๆที่เรา
ได้ยินใช่ไหมคะ
ก็ฝากจอนนี่เป็นจอนใช่ไหม Before นะคะ
แล้วก็ตกลงมาในนี้แต่ไม่ใช่แค่นั้นนะ
เจมส์บอกว่าตอน
นายอยู่ข้างล่างใช่ไหม
เดี๋ยวอีก 5 นาที
[เพลง]
ฉันเนี่ยจะมีสายยางใช่ไหม
แล้วก็น้ำ
จะใส่น้ำลงมา
มีน้ำใช่มีน้ำมีน้ำเดี๋ยวอีก 5 นาทีเจมส์
เนี่ยจะใส่น้ำลงไปในหลุม
เห็นไหม
มันไม่ใช่แค่ว่าคุณจะตกไปอยู่ในหลุมแล้ว
จะทำยังไงไม่ตายนะคะ
ผู้หญิงมันก็ดีสิ
ใส่น้ำลงมาเราก็ว่ายน้ำขึ้นไปไง
แต่ตอนนี้
ซอนว่ายน้ำไม่เป็น
ครูฟ้าว่ายน้ำเป็นใช่ไหมคะ
เป็นค่ะเพราะว่ายน้ำเป็นนะคะ
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยเหมือนจอห์นค่ะผู้หญิงก็ว่าย
น้ำไม่เป็นเราต้องว่ายน้ำอย่างนี้หรอ
แต่จรเนี่ยว่ายน้ำไม่เป็นไง
ตอนก็เลยกลัวมากๆถ้าเจมส์เนี่ยเอาน้ำใส่
ลงมา
น้ำมันก็จะเพิ่มขึ้นเพิ่มขึ้นเพิ่มขึ้น
ใช่ไหม
ก่อนก็อาจจะไปได้
จนเขาก็เขาก็ไม่ได้ยืนรอเฉยๆหรอกค่ะครู
ฟ้า
ในระหว่างที่ยังมีเวลา
5 นาทีใช่ไหมเพราะว่าเจมส์บอกว่าอีก 5
นาที
ถึงจะใส่น้ำใส่น้ำ
ลงมาจอนก็มีเวลา 5 นาทีเขาก็เลยมองมองไป
รอบๆหลุม
ครูฟ้าอ่านออกนะคะ
ป้าอ่านออกนักเรียนอ่านไม่ออกนะคะ
เดี๋ยวนักเรียนจะคิดว่าอะไร
นี่จอห์นเนี่ยนะคะเขาก็เลยมองไปในรอบๆใน
หลุมใช่ไหมเพราะว่าเราไม่อยากตายเราก็จะ
คิดว่าทำไอจะหนีแล้วก็ขึ้นไปบนหลุมได้ก็
ต้องมองว่าเอ๊ะมีอะไรที่จะช่วยเราได้บ้าง
ก็อย่างแรกเลยนะคะก็จะมีเสื้อนี่เชือก 1
เส้นอยู่ตรงนี้นะคะเชือกเส้นนี้เนี่ยนะคะ
ยาว
เชือกนะ 1 จุด 8 เมตรคือเมตรมันอาจจะแบบ
ยากหน่อยนะคะเพราะว่ามันเป็นฟุตมาก่อนไง
แต่คนไทยไม่เข้าใจฟุดนะคะ
เซนติเมตร 1.8 เมตรก็คือ 100
[เพลง]
180 เซนติเมตร
จะสีอะไรเนี่ยจะได้มองเห็นชัดๆนะ
เห็นชัดค่ะผู้หญิง
ต่อนะ
ขอบคุณค่ะครูฟ้า 180 เซนติเมตร 1 มีเชือก
ที่ยาว 1.8 เมตรหรือว่า 180 ซม
แล้วก็ 2
2 นะคะ
มีถังน้ำอันนี้นะอันนี้คือถังน้ำนะคะเป็น
ถังไม้นะคะถังน้ำเนี่ยสูงนี่มันสูงเนาะ
สูง
1.2 เมตรนะคะหรือว่า
เท่ากับ
120 เซนติเมตร
ถังน้ำ
แล้วก็ 3
ก็คืออันนี้นะคะที่นักเรียนเห็นอยู่
อันนี้คือ
เขาเรียกอะไรนะ
ตู้เซฟนะคะขอบคุณค่ะตู้เซฟนะคะตู้เซฟนี่
หนักอยู่เหมือนกันนะ
สูง
เซนติเมตรก็คือไม่ถึง 1 เมตร 90
เซนติเมตรนะคะแล้วก็จอนเนี่ยจรสูง
100  180
เซนติเมตรก็คือเท่ากับเชือกเนาะ
เท่ากับเชือกออกมาก็คือสูงเท่ากับจอนอัน
นี้คือมีของอยู่ 3 อย่างแล้วก็หลุมนะคะ
หลุมเนี่ย
หลุมเนี่ยลึก
เท่าไหร่เนี่ย
อ้าวเท่าไหร่
หาไม่เจอขอโทษทีนะคะก็เลยนานไปหน่อย 6
เมตรหรือว่า
600 เซนติเมตรถูกป่ะ
อ่า
[เพลง]
แล้วก็มีของให้ช่วย 3 อย่างก็คือมีเสื้อ
มีถัง
น้ำมีตู้เซฟที่ความยาวความสูงจะไม่เท่า
กันของพวกนี้จะช่วยให้จอห์นเนี่ยนะคะ
ขึ้นไปบนปากหลุมได้
แม็กจอยก็ต้องใช้ของแล้วก็ช่วยช่วยตัวเขา
นะคะให้ขึ้นไปแล้วจะทำยังไงถ้าเป็นครูฟ้า
ครูฟ้าเป็นจอนอุ้ย
อะไรคะ
จะได้เข้าใจเนาะ
ครูฟ้าจะทำยังไงจะใช้อะไรที่จะช่วยให้ครู
ฟ้า
ขึ้นไปข้างบนได้จากตัวช่วยก็คือมีเชือกมี
ถังน้ำแล้วก็มีตู้เซฟ
ยังไงล่ะเขาก็ไม่รู้นะคะนักเรียน
ใช่ค่ะครูหญิงดูผู้หญิงก็ไม่รู้หรอกค่ะ
แต่นี่คือเกมของครูหญิงนะคะ
รู้แล้วเชื่อ
มัดกัน
แล้วก็ผูกคอนะ
ไม่ได้ให้จนตายค่ะ
เอาเสื้อหรือว่าถังน้ำหรือว่าตู้เซฟเนี่ยทำให้ตัวเองเนี่ยขึ้นไปข้างบนเพราะว่าเดี๋ยวอีก
5 นาที
น้ำจะลงมาแล้ว
ครูฟ้าแบบตายเลยไม่ได้ค่ะชื่อว่าเกม
Survival
นะคะโจรต้องหนีหนีจากหลุมเช่นไปถ้าทำยังไงให้ตายไม่ต้องทำอะไรก็ได้ค่ะรอ
5 นาทีเดี๋ยวน้ำลงมาเออ
[เพลง]
กูฟ้าจะทำยังไง
ฟ้าก็ลองคิดสิว่าตู้นิรภัยเนี่ยมันสูงเท่าไหร่ทางน้ำสูงเท่าไหร่จอนสูงเท่าไหร่เชื่อยาวเท่าไหร่แล้วก็หลุมลึกเท่าไหร่อย่างนี้ค่ะ
คิดว่าจะทำยังไง
ก็ได้นะบางคนชอบคิดเป็นเลขใช่ไหมถ้าเรา
เอาถังมาวางตรงนี้เราก็จะได้ประมาณ
2.7 เมตร
ใช่ไหมอ่าแล้วก็จอนขึ้นไปอยู่ตรงนี้ก็บวก
ไป
1.8 เป็นเท่าไหร่เนี่ย
90  11  12  13  14  15
4.5 เมตรแต่หลุมลึก 6 เมตรเลยนะ
ได้แค่ 4.5 ก็ยังขึ้นไม่ได้เชื่อทำอะไร
ได้นี่คือคนที่คิดเป็นเลขไงคะเอามาบวกเอา
มาบวกเอามาลบกันทำยังไงแต่ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ไม่นะคะครูฟ้าคิดว่าทำยังไงครูฟ้าจะทำยัง
ไง
คิดออกไหม
เราก็ต้องเอามาต่อกันนะคะนักเรียนถ้าเรา
มีปี 2 อันนะฮะ
เอามาต่อกันก็คือเอาถังมาต่อไว้ข้างบนเขา
เรียกว่าอะไรถังมาวางไว้ข้างบนตู้ไหมหรือ
เอาโซ่มาวางไว้บนถังนะคะ
ดูมันหนักไง
[เพลง]
เอาเชือก
เกี่ยวกับหินไหม
แล้วเราก็ปีนขึ้นไป
แล้วคุณมองเห็นนะคุณจะมองเห็นหินข้างบน
ไหม
ก็โยนไปก่อน
เราก็ทำได้นะ
ไม่ได้เหรอ
คะ
[เพลง]
แล้วก็ปีนเสื้อโอ๊ะมันมีแค่นิดเดียวเองนะ
เพราะว่าทั้งสอง
น้ำแล้วก็ตู้เซฟไว้เท่าไหร่นะผู้หญิงบวก
เอาไว้อ่ะ
4.5 ป่ะ
4.5
4.5 เมตรใช่ไหมเพราะว่าเป็น
อะไรนะ 1
เอ้ยไม่ใช่ผู้หญิงบวกผิดหรือเปล่าเนี่ย
ถังไม้เนี่ย
1.2  +  John  1.8 ก็เท่ากับ 3  + ตู้
นิรภัยโอเค 3.9 ไม่ใช่ 4.5 นะคะนักเรียน
3.9
3.9 เมตรใช่ไหมคะแล้วหลุมเนี่ยลึก 6
เมตรก็ลบกันเหลือ 1
เมตรเลยนะ
ที่เราต้องเอาเสื้อเสื้อก็ไม่ได้วะคุณฟ้า
เอง
[เพลง]
จุด 8
จอก็กระโดดเอาไง
กระโดดกระโดดเอาอันนี้วิธีของครูฟ้านัก
เรียนลองคิดดูว่าถ้านักเรียนเป็นจรแล้วมี
เสื้อมีถังน้ำมีตู้มีตู้เซฟเนี่ยนะคะนัก
เรียนจะทำยังไงนักเรียนลองคิดนะติ๊กต๊อก
ติ๊กต๊อกคิดว่านักเรียนคิดเสร็จแล้วครู
หญิงจะเฉลยเลยแล้วกันนะคะว่าทำยังไงเพราะ
ว่าเดี๋ยวอีก 5 นาทีใช่ไหมคะอีก 5 นาที
เนี่ยน้ำเนี่ยจะลงมาแล้วเขาก็บอกว่าก็
เดี๋ยวน้ำมันจะลงมาใช่ไหม
ก็จอห์นเนี่ยก็กอดถังไม้เอาไว้ไม่ต้องสน
ใจไม่ต้องสนใจเชื่อไม่ต้องสนใจตู้เซฟ
เนี่ยถังน้ำเนี่ยแหละค่ะ
เนี่ยกอดถังน้ำเอาไว้ใช่ไหมแล้วพอคนบ้า
ใส่น้ำลงมา
เวลาน้ำมันเยอะขึ้นเยอะขึ้นเนี่ยถังน้ำ
เนี่ยมันจะลอยลอยมันไม่จม
ถ้าดูซิว่าตู้นิรภัยเนี่ยมันจมอยู่ในนี้
ใช่ไหมคะมันไม่ได้ลอยขึ้นมาเพื่อเนี่ยมัน
ก็จมแต่ถังน้ำเนี่ยที่เป็นไม้เนี่ย
มันลอยน้ำได้ไง
พอจ้อนมั้ย
ก็รอให้น้ำลงมาแล้วลูกจอนก็ขึ้นไป
อย่างนี้ค่ะว่าทางน้ำมันมีน้ำไหมหรือเรา
จะเอาน้ำออกมาจากถังแล้วเราก็ลอยขึ้นมา
นิดนึงแล้วเราก็เอาอะไรมาวาง
คิดตอนนั้นแล้วครูหญิงบอกว่าถูกเลยอ่ะมัน
จะสนุกหรอ
ว่ายน้ำใช่ไหมด้วยไง
ก็รอให้น้ำลงมาตอนยกขึ้นไป
เออแล้วครูฟ้าพูดตั้งแต่คลาสเพิ่งเริ่มไป
ประมาณ 7 นาทีอย่างเงี้ย
แล้วอีก 13 นาทีผู้หญิงทำอะไรอ่ะ
e3 วินาที
อะไรอ่ะกูฟ้าผู้หญิงก็ต้องบอก
สะออนว่ายน้ำไม่เป็นไงก็เจ็บว่ายน้ำเป็น
ผู้หญิงก็ไม่ผิดนะคะแต่วิธีครูฟ้าก็ถูก
แล้วไงตอนแรกแค่ครูฟามไม่คิดให้ดีๆไม่มอง
ให้ได้ดีฟังครูหญิงมากเกินไปเห็นไหมคะก็
ไม่ต้องกลัวไม่ตายแล้วแค่นี้จนกอดถังน้ำ
เอาไว้แล้วก็ลอยขึ้นตอนก็ขึ้นมาบนปากหลุม
ได้แต่ตอนขึ้นเนี่ยอีกทีนึงนะคะเห็นมั้ย
จอห์นก็หนีได้แล้วเออนักเรียนคิดว่าไหม
ถ้านักเรียนคิดเหมือนครูฟ้าก็คอมเมนต์บอก
เราได้นะคะแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้หมดเวลาแล้ว
เนาะเดี๋ยวเราเจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้านะคะ
นักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
[เพลง]